[Music]
prove you're smiling I like that let's
take a look at your response did you
come up with the right one no what is we
love you out that's very kind thank you
it was the sweet moment that went viral
and had us all reaching for the tissues
my mom texted me and she was like you're
trending on Twitter and I was like okay
mom like eight tweets is it trending and
then she was like no really like check
and and we love you Alex was like in the
top 10 trending hashtags on Twitter I'm
a lucky guy I'm really lucky jeopardy
contestant Dhruv Gower opened up about
the heartwarming exchange during a stop
by Ellen so we actually shot it in mid
September it was right after Alex had
actually announced publicly that he was
gonna reenter chemotherapy for his
pancreatic cancer and we could really
tell that like it was tough for him so
you know when I got up there like
obviously I wasn't gonna win the game or
anything so I was like I could try to
figure out the right answer or you know
I could do something for this person who
might need it right now
stars like Chrissy Teigen and Ryan
Reynolds shared the moment on social
media and if you like me feel like you
couldn't love this kid anymore
think again Dhruv wants to make the most
of his viral moment a lot of contestants
on the tournament and I are gonna be
doing tonight and tomorrow night is
during the finals of the tournament of
champions that will be airing we're
gonna be playing along at home and for
every question we get right we're gonna
donate a dollar to the lush garden
foundation to support pancreatic cancer
research the game show host announced in
March that he had been diagnosed with
cancer this week I was diagnosed with
stage 4 pancreatic cancer now normally
the prognosis for this is not very
encouraging but I'm gonna fight this
despite his diagnosis he's continued to
host the show in between his
chemotherapy treatments
what does all that support mean to you
it's blowing me away I told somebody the
other day that most of us in our
lifetimes never get to know the impact
we've had on other people
you only hear about it after the person
passes away and to be able to experience
it while you're alive is very special it
just it touches me at a very deep level
what do you want your legacy to be how
do you want us to remember you just as a
good guy a nice man and somebody that
you looked at on television on a daily
basis and said hey you know what I like
him of course you can count on et to
bring you all the sweet stories out of
Hollywood like this one so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]